yeah I think I'm just a little pervert
dude she could do [__] anything she
could fart in my face and I'd be like
[Music]
welcome back to another careful boys and
we are very careful boys we got touch
back and hey hello hey Josh today we're
going to talk about what does the
opposite sex do or your favorite sex do
that turns you on the most
wow exist
let's go what turns me on
irresistible yeah accidental shoulder
bump I mean honestly drop things and
pick it up whoever wants to play video
games with me is cool with me
that's a great one yeah I'm at that
stage in my life because I feel like
that's that's that's tough though for a
lot of ladies to like sit down and like
want to play video games but not like
Mario Brothers right don't think I'll
play Mario Brothers Mario your girl
plays video games with you oh yeah what
games Mario Kart oh I love Mario Kart
dude she's really good like when people
are like I can beat you in Mario Kart I
just go if you can beat her then you can
complain wow so when you guys play who
wins it's me
it's so annoying she kills me she kills
all my neighbors she kills everybody how
does it feel to be emasculated like that
it's just used to it apparently because
like yeah it just destroys and destroys
and destroys me I keep on going back for
more but but because I want to beat her
I genuinely do but yeah she just gets
better she gets better and better my
wife wanted to get this game for the
switch called um like a Untitled Goose
game and you're just a goose that walks
around and like does tasks yeah and it's
just like a fun kind of game and it's
like very simple but when I watch her
play
it makes me want to jump out of like a
movie you don't wanna because I'm like
I'm like babe it's like no no not that
eight like just use your other use your
other joystick go you gotta go around
the fact the Dual joystick thing can be
tough for people who don't play video
games yeah it's like her battle is like
here but just understanding like her
relation with her moving her hands and
then with the character it's like a
child I'm just like yeah it's hard like
babe you gotta pick it up you gotta you
gotta move to the side a little bit to
pick up it's like watching someone run
with a broken neck oh like if you if
you're probably not possible in real
life but someone if you could somehow
just break your neck and it can hang and
like just turn but like you're running
in the opposite direction
that was my dad playing 007 you're like
oh yeah it was like dude when she plays
does she turn with her body
no she doesn't she doesn't I've seen a
lot of people it's just more of like
just not even getting to that stage yet
it's more of a just like kind of
figuring out what this thing is you know
what this game is dude that's what
happened I was playing Super Mario World
remember that game classic game with my
neighbor my next door neighbor and it
was like basically socialism
because I'm so like in that game if you
if we play as Mario Luigi you share
lives yeah oh yeah so I'm watching this
so like you get pissed yeah like you
know we have like eight lives that's it
and then every time he [__] dies he
basically like as soon as he hands gets
handed the controller he dies and then I
keep on having to give him my lives and
I'm like this son of a [__] is I'm dead
wait
this is what you know the like the side
scrolling beat em up games yeah like
back in the day you had to share lives I
mean you always if you had a partner
that sucked it's you're just like it's
this you're like dude we can't get past
the third level because you [__] suck
I wouldn't want my significant other to
play games with me just because are you
too good because no I want to reserve my
game time for me it's like a selfish
bastard but watch porn with me but like
I want to jack off to what I want to
Jack
because when you play games
like you either get like super
competitive or if it's a co-op they're
not pooling so I think everyone should
go home and play overcooked
bad idea in the comments section
everyone go home and download overcooked
I have disowned my sister dude
in real life
oh yeah that's right
dude we gotta [__]
a [__] shop and [__] you're like kind of
dishes I know he goes I'm at the [__]
register what the [__] are you doing I
don't know what the [__] are you doing
you know somebody cut up the protein
when you get a squad that does well and
works well together overcooked oh it's
nothing's better nothing is better than
that that's when you're that's when you
guys go hey let's start another jumbia
out here
I think we have to play it dude I think
if you took the whole Junior Team yeah
and played overcook yeah your sales
would Skyrocket like 500 percent they've
become so efficient no one would speak
to each other nice nice can I land on
you guys while you're doing that
is there a way I can [__] around in that
game
yeah no the way you sabotage the game is
just by being a jackass that's what
makes the game great because if you fail
at your task you're like what's wrong
with you you just have to you just have
to cut up lettuce so you're [__]
stupid
you're like I don't get it you just have
to hit a just [__] hit a bring the
lettuce to the table
that's the [__] dishes I'm talking to
the customers my character I think my
character's going through something so I
can't watch Lotus right now all right
you're gonna serve the customers then
you need a mental health day yeah yeah
that's why I'm a master at customer
service you know Food Service I'm an
actor spend more time in the restaurant
than I do on set so it's great what so
no but okay so other than video games
[Laughter]
cemented that one I'm uh honestly
truthfully
I'd like anything with like a good smile
like I'm a teen person teeth yeah like
you have a good smile yeah that'll get
my attention
I like a woman that shops
shops till she drops
because then so then he doesn't have to
spend any time yeah yeah yeah not like a
woman that likes to vet a lot all day
every year you've got a chick you don't
have to play to them I know what else
you want a menstruator
at least once a month did they go
shopping for your outfit today I like
the fluffy texture from tote from head
to toe didn't you find that hat
this one
um was that your shirt was that uh uh it
was that Daiso for a dollar fifty what a
funny message yeah that's just feel good
yeah I feel good feel good nothing else
dude looking at it makes me feel good
thank you thank you hey what about what
about yeah what about you guys single
dude yeah what kind of girls do you like
what kind of girls or what do I like
what turns you on what goes
uh if they make me laugh dude sense of
humor is always the best because do I
make you laugh you're really hard to
make but what about us are you turned on
by us since we just made you laugh no
silly okay all right oh so there's a
limit yeah no I guess comedy isn't the
answer it's a it's it's like what you
laugh at because sometimes when you
laugh with your boys it's like you're
laughing at dumb [__] but then when you
laugh with a girl you laugh with a
baller what's the last thing what's the
last thing a girl did to make you laugh
yeah what did you laugh at with a girl I
can't remember it's been so long but you
remember what was the last thing you
laughed with with your boys do you
remember
oh wait what the last thing I laughed at
with my boys I don't know it's like just
like dumb [__] like you know and it
literally anything we could be laughing
at like accents or something so who do
you love more your boys or your girls I
love everybody
good answer but yeah sense of humor and
um I I guess how you guys like talk to
each other like the way you communicate
does it turn you on if a girl speaks
Vietnamese no really hi because it makes
me feel like I'm talking to my sister oh
does that turn you off okay but what if
means like let's say
okay right yeah she's Ethiopian and she
studied Vietnamese to be closer to you
so she busts out the Vietnamese would
you go oh that's an egg roll time
I think that would be funny it would be
funny yeah it'd be funny because then I
could do my Vietnamese jokes yeah if at
least it's a really hot chick is talking
to you but she's talking to Vietnamese
that's your sister you're throwing up
yeah
that's a system I'm thinking about
actually maybe I don't know I wouldn't
know it would ruin ruin it all have you
ever dated a Vietnamese girl that speaks
Vietnam uh no not really really yeah
well because uh attraction is like if
I'm not attracted to that because it's
hard it's hard to there's nothing wrong
with it if you're racist it's fine if
you're racist dude everyone's
significant other is not it's from a
different culture yeah everyone's
significant others from a different
culture yeah yeah yeah see how do you
feel about that why are you looking down
on us no I'm not I'm just curious no
cause you were talking about he's
judging us are you up here looking down
here
you know you know how it goes yeah just
stick to your own kind but it's fine
that's right in India it like doesn't
even matter because you're from a
different city you speak a different
language like at least if in you know
other countries the language is
consistent yeah but like an India if
you're from North India and then you
know I'm from South India everyone
speaks different languages interesting
so it's like nah dude [__] that go get
someone from your own City or your own
village so you're going to speak the
same language that's important
apparently all you need is a set of
teeth though yeah for me it's just a
smile it's a dental love you just need
to be about smiles speak English and
play Mario okay that's pretty good
looking down it's pretty high for 10.
you have a different list yeah
definitely the 30s are weird Mario Kart
wasn't on the list I'll tell you that
today's video is brought to you by
Hannah love so treat yourself to the
best shapewear on the market and save 20
off at honeywell.com with the code OTR
it's called OTR honeylove.com you know
what's up about honey love what it's
done I never put that on even though I
am a connoisseur of women's clothing I'm
more like smelling it
but when I see Geo awareness and this
makes me happy sometimes because she's
being Mama now so sometimes she can't be
getting in the gym but you know on
YouTube we got to go to events and stuff
and she's like man I can't squeeze into
that dress to get that hour figure that
I used to have so she'd go and then just
squeezes all the things into the right
places and then bam she could Now put on
her favorite dress and look the way she
wants to
um
we're talking about shapewear honey
loves best-selling superpower short is
the go-to it has targeted compression
technology and I've seen a working
person it distinguishes between areas
where you want more support and areas
where you need less compression I'm
talking about I'm talking about here is
less and then
the super power short is helping ladies
everywhere sculpt and smooth from
stomach to thigh by offering just the
perfect amount of compression the things
that ladies do to just achieve such a
great figure I'm like wow I do
appreciate it I appreciate the effort I
like it really I like it but also at the
same time I look and I'm like I hope
you're comfortable
because it looks sexy yeah I also think
it's dope because sometimes in a pinch
you can go and then you're like I'm
gonna work it out anyways treat yourself
to the best shapewear on the market and
say 20 off at honeylove.com with the
code
OTR is called OTR honeylove.com do you
think the older you get that lists
shrinks hell yeah of course
especially if it hasn't been working out
but he's got a chip it's different I'm
lucky yeah I'm good hey you want to know
a new one recently I don't know why but
since we got these puppies in the house
anytime my lady does anything like kind
of motherly I'm like yes
that's 30. anytime anytime she shows any
sign of like and I know it's just a pup
you know what I mean yeah but in our way
this is our test run before we have kids
it's valid yeah and she like Picks Them
Up I'm like oh my God that's cute that's
human again you know it's a big one for
me
I'm gonna say [__] you're talking to
the dog
I think a big one for me is the way that
um they treat servers yes
if they treat them well I don't like
this
gotta treat him like a servant we're
better than them yeah what are you doing
another one is he
another one is like kind of like what
you said is is just being a kid Magnet
or like like being a [__] what do you
call that what's that one girl in the
Disney movies that attracts all the
animals and [__] Kim Kardashian yeah
no I do like I do like it when girls
like animals like if they're really cool
with cats Snow White yeah Snow White I
thought you said they're cool
not two bro you know how to like get
Brownie good brownie good good cookie if
she does like shrimp chocolates I'm like
really into her oh
one thing one thing I really like which
I discovered just randomly was uh so my
my girlfriend smack she does commercials
and she's actor and stuff and uh one day
we got approached to go to this audition
together
and I she looks like crazy she always
got tons of Nationals going on and I'm
like she must be really good and then we
went together and I saw how she acted
and how she won over the casting like
you're like damn I was like holy [__]
wonder and then of course we booked it
because she just like works this magic
where'd she do she's just really good at
auditioning like auditions like you know
like well I always say this uh for
actors auditioning is our job working
the job is the vacation yeah because you
don't get hired much she's just
I mean that's why I'm here on the show
oh my I gotta feed some of myself when I
saw like and I can't even like imitate
it but like it's a personality that she
puts on that we don't even have at home
like I don't see her act like that with
me ever but to see her do it it was like
just like who is this person this is
dope it's not professionalism yeah and
it was just like like that's clean yeah
that's the type of [__] into that to see
your your uh to see a girl in her in her
mode in her professionalism is really
really cool do you think she would feel
the same seeing you like going on tour
and like doing your thing no because I
would be surrounded by [__]
yeah I believe all women paid anymore
but I'll be honest that's my [__] guy
I've I've been training I've been
training with Nick and I feel the same
way when I see him at the gym
thanks bro I appreciate that I never
seen him in this element I'm like oh wow
you're looking I'm beating up men yeah
it feels like that you know
I'm like exactly I'm like oh you're
wearing a little less clothing she's
crazy he's yelling at me a little bit
more I'm like dude can can you get your
elbow out of my mouth like can you do
that are you training too like feel
right here Tish right here right here
he's too scared to roll with me because
he knows he'll never let go
I think we've done mental pretty good
now what physical [__] do they do oh
this is the best part
short shorts let's skip to this part
short
shorts leggings for me yeah um like the
Lulu lemons lemons dude Nikki commits
Warfare in my house with leggings dude
it's like I know it's [__] on
big t-shirt wait physical or like
fashion or like what are we talking
about you're talking like body
attributes or if you like fashion if
that's something that you I like it when
um they wear like really big shirts and
like you can't you can't tell if they're
wearing like but like their legs yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh like big t-shirts
yeah yeah yeah
[__]
thing all of us just don't tell we'll
all wear tall tees no pants oh [__] I'm
gonna just wear knee-high socks too oh
dude that's a killer I don't know
everything dude I'm not it really is
it's like what do you like though come
on but like for me personally you can be
incredibly attractive but if you can't
make me laugh if you can't make me laugh
what is your girl do yeah yeah but like
what I like everyone's booing you
everyone's booing the comments are going
wild rather they're like this dude he's
normal yeah oh he wants everybody long
hair long hair or short hair hey are you
attracted to when you're are you turned
on by when your girl dresses in like
traditional Indian attire yes
but here's the thing asari is exposing
see if Bart was here he'd be like yeah
dude the Auntie lives across the street
I keep seeing your fat gut because he
always ask me that like that's the thing
like aunties this is a thing Auntie's in
India
sorry it's very traditional clothing
you'll always see their their stomach
and like nobody cares and Bart's always
like why are they showing you he's upset
by it I'm like dude I don't know why
does that [__] have a six-pack yeah
he's like what the [__] he's just
looking out he's trying to sell his
program dude he's trying to sell good
luck yeah he just I'm like Bart you
should start a Brigade sorry
get people on it's squatting and stuff
but I'm I like it dude Indian
traditional clothing is just like it's
just a sheet even for men longies
because it's always so hot yeah so it's
like who cares everyone's sweating
if I could see my lady's outline of her
butt just a little bit in any clothes it
doesn't matter yep it doesn't matter
even if it's like a not flattering pair
I'm like oh and I can't call her
constantly oh baby like something like
that you have a you have a line do you
whistle can you whisk sometimes I'll say
something and I'll be like it even if
I'm joking I'll be like
why what did you say I just get
self-conscious oh you you cancel
yourself in the moment I'm like babe you
look so good and I'm like was that bad
I was like is that creepy
question yourself this is not a [__]
joke can okay this is my real life
anyway
can no that's it's real though listen
we're not talking about tall TV all
right yeah
because it's funny because she won't
I'll say stupid [__] sir all the time so
she won't give me a reaction so I think
that's her default it's not be like baby
looks so good she goes thanks and I'm
like
does she she speaks uh Spanish right
yeah is that turn you on not
particularly not not like not like out
of the ordinary oh like not because she
speaks Spanish is like I can't speak you
know what I mean like I kind of know do
you speak Spanish with her at all no I
don't know
they speak Spanish and I'm always like
they'll say they'll have a conversation
amongst each other and then I'll chime
in and go did you guys were you guys
talking about this and they go yeah
yeah good job and then I'll get cocky
and I'll start naming more things you
guys were talking about the bookshelf in
the living room and they're like no
we're talking about the candles and I
was like oh yeah I'm close I heard
people attack guys yeah yeah I don't
know books maybe they're all trying to
have a conversation excuse me did you
guys uh it's like a game show yeah and
they go ah I think all this guy's a
[__] idiot yeah so that's our in-law
life you know but as far as like
yeah I think I'm just a little pervert
dude yeah she could do [__] anything
she could fart in my face and I'd be
like
I tell her that you say [__] in your
face what'd you say I'm not [__] I just
want to make sure I heard you don't do
that over here repeat that again and I
think also too like she gets really
weird about it like she's like oh God
like you know she might be like oh my
stomach isn't like feeling good Baby
you're like let me squeeze you let me
roll one out yeah yeah yeah yeah get a
rolling pin [__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then she'll be
like no no stop stop let me show you
this inescapable Jiu Jitsu hold let me
just squeeze your little orange chest
fart on my dick that's how we do it and
then she always gets like super like
stop and I'm like all right are you
seriously I hate stop because I because
sometimes it's go yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and that's true sometimes it is oh
man sometimes I'm not really good
that's why I play a lot of Mario Kart
yeah yeah yeah yeah because go is go
yeah because go is go baby and there is
no stop first place or bus so so Nick
likes butts I see yeah he also likes his
wife can yeah you forget the most
important part of that sentence when
Tasha's training at the gym I'm always
like objectifying his cheeks I'm like
yeah it actually makes me feel really
good I'm always asking if I can if I can
back squat and he's like no it's not
it's too big dude it's too big what
exactly are you training he's just
getting stronger he's trying to lift
come on don't get jealous man we're
trying to make them get worse I want to
learn how to spit on my head too
Nick is teaching him how to break down I
think I see him do it like this you know
how many years I spent in my basement
just so that people wouldn't call me a
nerd trying to do Windmill flares and
then I realized
I'm a [__] nerd
you know the thing on the ground has
been practicing can show you I haven't
been practicing wow I've been practicing
this
but my mind you're already good at that
my robots are legit my robot's legit
nice you think it was better than that
piece of trash still makes you a nerd
though because this is pretty nerdy I
saw Shakira doing it I don't think
that made me cool I'll never forget
eighth grade the social came back
I'll never I put duct tape on my Allen
Iverson sneakers so I could moon walk in
the gym at the eighth grade dance but
did it Blow everyone's mind oh yeah they
were like what the [__] they're like
first of all who is this kid yeah yeah
do we know him that's when your life
started they're like is this who's when
did this Mexican kid join us
Puerto Rican yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
tape to moonwalk yeah and then I
graduated and I took that off because
then I was just slipping in the rain and
[__] twisting my ankle falling down
without duct tape okay
that was the worst view to do
I don't know he was like let me do it
off camera hey do it I thought you're a
[__] dancer
okay